So, first things first, we're going to be creating a new landscape.
And to do that, what we're going to do first is we're going to create a new basic level.
And then once we do that, we're going to go ahead and click over to our landscape tool
to activate it.
Then once our tool is activated, what we're going to do here is we're going to make sure
that the location is set to 000, that our section size is set to something relatively
small.
Section sizes could control how many quads our landscape is, and making them bigger
is going to result in a larger landscape, making that number smaller is going to result
in a smaller landscape.
And then we're going to hit create.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now and do this whole process.
So again, file new level, select the basic right here, going to hit create.
Then what I'm going to do is I'm going to select this static mesh here that represents
our floor and hit delete.
That's going to go ahead and delete that because we're making a landscape.
We don't actually need that.
Next we're going to come up here to our selection mode and come down to landscape.
And once we do that, it's going to activate our landscape tool.
Now since we don't have a landscape in the view yet, this is what we're going to see.
This green outline represents where our landscape is going to be.
Make sure our location is in 000, that's good.
We're going to leave the scale exactly as it is.
And I'm going to take my section size, maybe down to 15 by 15, just to make my landscape
a little bit smaller and a little easier to manage for this example.
Once all of that has been done, I'm going to go ahead and hit the create button.
And you're going to see here my landscape is ready to be painted on.
So in the next section of this video, what we're going to be taking a look is at how
to use the various sculpting tools to sculpt our landscape.
So I'll see you in just a bit.